[تصفيق]
جربت كل شيء لدعم اوكرانيا وها هي تتحضر
لارسال النووي هل جنه جنون الاوروبيين يا
ساده وكيف تحشد المواطنين للقتال دون
تدريب قائله سوف تعلمكم
يتخذ خطوه خطيره بخصوص اوكرانيا فكيف سيرد
بوتين والصين تقدم مقترحه سلام بشرط واحد
فما هو هذا الشرط وهولندا تعلن موعد دوزها
على خط بوتين الاحمر بينما تعلن صربيا عن
حاله التاهب القصوى والحرب تندلع معكوسومو
الصين تحث الدول اوروبا على شريك تجاري
اقوى من الولايات المتحده ذاتها والبنك
الدولي يقدم هديه لللبنانيين والسودان
يدعو كل من يقدر على
النهايه لا تقترب سيناريو الرصاصه الاخيره
غير وارد في حرب اوكرانيا وما من مؤشر
لنهايه قريبه للقتال ليعلنها نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
انه يتوقع ان يستمر الصراع لعقود بينما
ترى واشنطن بدورها ان الطرفين الاوكراني
والروسي لن يتمكن في المستقبل القريب من
تحقيق اهداف مادريد انه طالما ظل النظام
الاوكراني الحالي والمهرج الزينسكي في
السلطه فان المحادثات ستكون مستحيله وفق
تعبيره بحسب وكاله تاسا وهنا تاتي هولندا
من بعيد لتتجاوز اشاره بوتين الحمراء حيث
افادت وكاله نقلا عن مصادرها المطلعه انه
من المرجح ان ترسله لندى طائرات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا بعد تدريب الطيارين ما سيستغرق
عده اشهر اي ان ارسال الطائرات اف 16
لاوكرانيا سيكون منتصف العام المقبل بحسب
بلنبرغ ليشير وزير الدفاع الامريكي الى
بدء تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين خلال
الاسابيع المقبله تحت قياده برنامج تدريب
من الدنمارك وهولندا من جانبهم الاوكران
استبشروا خيرا بموعد وصول الطائرات لتكشف
انها بحاجه الى 48 مقاتله امريكيه من طراز
اف 16 للعوده الى ما سمته بحدود عام 91
لكن مهلا مهلا ما الذي باستطاعه 48 طائره
ان تفعله امام اسطول الدب الروسي
المخيديف
بوصله حديثي نحو اوروبا بقوله ان القاره
العجوز اصبحت مجنونه وتحاول تاجيج الوضع
ولم يستبعد ان تقدم الدول الاوروبيه والول
المتحده على تزويد كييف باسلحه نوويه ما
الذي تقوله يا هذا ومن ذا الذي يجرؤ على
خطوه نوويه كهذه لكن دعوني اقول لكم عن
خطوه واقعيه اكثر فتصاعد التوتر اكثر بين
الغرب وموسكو وتسوق الاحداث نحو مواجهه
مباشره حيث يعتزم حلف النيتو الاقتراح على
اوكرانيا رفع وضعها الى مستوى شريك في
الخلف وذلك دون المساسي بموضوع ضمها كعضو
في النيتو بينما لا تزال الخطط المحدده
للعضويه في النيتو بعيده المنال عن
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
ومن مسارات الحرب الى مبادرات السلام وبعد
تصريحات المستشار الالماني حول نيته
الاتصال بالرئيس الروسي من اجل التفاوض
بشان السلام في اوكرانيا ردى متحدث
باي حوار يصب في حمايه مصالح البلاد مشيرا
الى ان شورت لم يتصل بعد ومن جهاته
المبعوث الصيني لتسويه الازمه الاوكرانيه
الى الوقف الفوري للعمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا مع اقتراحه شرطا واحدا وهو
احتفاظ روسيا بالاراضي الجديده اي
المقاطعه الاربع وهي خرسون
فهل تقبل بذلك لنعد الى الحرب في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه حيث تكشف الصحف الامريكيه كل
يوم عن قضيه وازمه جديده واليوم كشفت
صحيفه بروسلي
انكيف دفعت بقوات غير مدربه وتعاني من نقص
واضح في المعدات الى مفرمه لحم بخموت خلال
معارك المدينه ووفقا للصحيفه حشد قادته
قوات من المواطنين دون تدريب وقالوا لهم
وهنا ننتقل الى ازمه عميقه ومعقده بين
واشنطن وموسكو حيث كان مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي قد اظهر موافقته على
الضربات التي شنتها التشكيلات المسلحه
للنظام في على اراضي روسيا بما في ذلك
جمهوريه القرم ومنطقه
الروسيه لياتي الرد الروسي فورا حيث
استدعت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه كبار
الدبلوماسي السفاره الامريكيه لدى موسكو
احتجاجا على التصريحات غير المقبوله من
سالفا وحذرت موسكو واشنطن من ان اي شكل من
اشكال العدوان ضد روسيا سيلقى حتما ردود
فعل اكثر صرامه وفق الخارجيه الروسيه
لتتواصل هنا المعارك بين الروس والامريكان
حيث قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
لمترميدف فان نتائج الانتخابات الامريكيه
لسنه
ستكون مقبوله بالنسبه لروسيا اذا لم تاتي
بشخص مصاب بالخرف رئيسا للولايات المتحده
مضيفا ان دونالد ترامب رجل طيب ولكنه جبان
حسب تعبير ومن روسيا الى صربيا حيث تطبخ
حرب جديده على نار هادئه هناك امر الرئيس
صربيا الكسندر بوضع الجيش في حاله تاهب
قتالي قصوى والاقتراب من الحدود مع كوسوفو
ليؤكد وزير الدفاع الصربي رفع جاهزيه
الجيش الى اقصى درجه من الاستعداد القتالي
وتقدمه نحو كوسوفو وفقا لما اوردته وكاله
وياتي هذا الاجراء بسبب الوضع المتوتر في
كوسوفو حيث تم انتخاب الباني عمده ببلديه
شمال رغم مقاطعه الاغلبيه الصربيه للتصويت
لتندلع اشتباكات واعمال
بين افراد من القوات الخاصه في كوسوفو
والصرف فلتتريت قليلا يا هؤلاء وابتعدوا
مما يجري في اوكرانيا فالحرب لا تاتي الا
بالاسواق الاحداث والتطورات
ذكرت صحيفه بولس جورنال ان الممثل الخاص
الصيني لشؤون اوراسيا حتى الدول الاوروبيه
على النظر الى الصين باعتبارها بديلا
تجاريا واقتصاديا عن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بينما قالت وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيين ان هناك تقارير تفيد باطلاق
الحكومه الامريكيه هجمات الكترونيه على
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه للصين واضافت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه انا بكين
ستتخذ التدابير اللازمه لمنع ووقف جميع
انواع الهجمات الالكترونيه التي تهدد امن
بنيه التحتيه وفق البنك الدولي تمويل
اضافي بقيمه ثلاثمائه مليون دولار للمشروع
الطارئ لدعم شبكه الامان الاجتماعي
للاستجابه للازمه وجائحه الكوفيد 19 في
لبنان دعا وزير الدفاع السوداني المكلف
الفريق ركني ياسين ابراهيم ياسين
المتقاعدين من منتسبي القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وكل القادرين على حمل السلاح
بالتوجه الى القياده العسكريه لتسليحهم
استخدم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خمسين اليه
وجرافتين لمداهمه مخيم عقبه في مدينه
اريحا ما ادى الى اصابه 13 فلسطينيين
بالرصاص الذي ينطلق من اسطح المنازل عبر
قناصه يستهدفون المدنيين كما من عتقوات
الاحتلال الهلال الاحمر من عمله بزعم منها
انها تنفذ عمليه امنيه لضبط مطلوبي قال
جيش الكيان انه اسقط مسيره اجتازت الحدود
الاسرائيليه
من جهه لبنان بينما تتجه اوكرانيا الى
خساره اراضيها تدريجيا امام القوات
الروسيه بكين تقدم اقتراحا يقلل الخسائر
على اوكرانيا فهل يقبل به الاوكرانيون
[موسيقى]